federal emergency management agency has
paid out around 85
million dollars in funeral expenses to
families who lost loved ones to the
coronavirus
but this program is out of reach for
many because of death certificates
that do not mention covet 19. manuel
bajorka spoke to one florida family
navigating the red tape he was full of
life
he has more energy than me
i did not expect that at all alexandra
hanau's father ricardo zamudio
died last year from covet 19. and that's
the cause listed on his death
certificate
so she's eligible for up to nine
thousand dollars in fema funeral
assistance
a big help for these working parents for
us financial wise it'll be a good help
but at the same time money don't mean
anything
we honestly wish we had our parents back
of course more than anything
oscar hanau's father oscar senior died
six months later
at 82. the day before he died i had the
opportunity to actually hold them see
him kiss him and thank him for
everything he has done
they say he died from covid19 after
testing positive
weeks before his death he was covet 19
but it wasn't on the death certificate
what happened there honestly i didn't
know what happened because they asked
they
when the funeral home asked us you know
what he died from they verified
everything was you know covet 19 but it
wasn't placed on
the death certificate fema's 2 billion
assistance program
is the largest of its kind in the
nation's history but eligibility is
strictly limited to loved ones who
present death certificates
stating the death was caused by may have
been caused by or was likely a result of
covet 19.
it is a process and in that process one
step is to make sure that cover 19 is
mentioned on the death certificate
mark panciera a partner at boyd panciera
family funeral care
has been guiding families through the
fema process including helping to amend
death certificates
your part could be considered done here
but some families are still coming back
to you to say can we get a little more
help this just
adds another element in it and we want
to be that guide on the side if you will
for the family
earlier this month fema administrator
deanne criswell told cbs
news that the process is intentionally
rigorous to protect against fraud
we've put controls in place to make sure
that we can
identify that and try to reduce any
potential opportunities for people to
take advantage of that program when they
shouldn't be
the hanals have had the certificate
amended and fema is reviewing their
application
this could especially be a problem for
those whose loved ones died early on in
the pandemic when testing was
insufficient
or doctors did not know to list covet 19
as a cause
fema says as with any new program it
continues to review and
update its policy for any changes that
need to be made
we hope everyone who deserves that money
gets it that was manuel bojorquez
reporting for us manny thank you very
much